ya van 30 años de la muerte de freddie
mercury una de las leyendas de la música
pop
e inolvidable vocalista del grupo
musical que revolucionó los 70
[Música]
artísticamente merco y desafío los
parámetros de los géneros del pop y el
rock arriesgando a su estilo musical y
alejándose del mainstream aunque
personalmente el artista fue muy
reservado llegando a asegurar que odiaba
hablar con extraños
todo el mundo me mira en el escenario y
piensa que soy así arrogante y cuando me
verás tú aquí ahora realmente soy
bastante aburrido
con metáforas ingeniosas melodías
originales y espontaneidad en el
escenario cada concierto de queens era
diferente y el timbre de voz de mercury
estudiado incluso por científicos
y su carisma en el escenario enamoraron
a miles de personas en todo el mundo
siempre he sido así el éxito ayuda y
hace más fácil ser llamativo lo que sea
pero no tener eso no me detendría si
todo mi dinero se fuera mañana no me
detendría
tal fue su alcance que ahora tres
décadas después de su muerte todavía es
un referente para muchos músicos y
artistas admiradores del excéntrico
cantante
si soy un hombre de extremos no creo que
sea de medias tintas o me entiendes o te
molesto soy muy tierno anderson con sólo
45 años y un día después de hacer
oficial que había contraído vih mercury
falleció y junto a queens dejó un legado
musical que los expertos estiman nunca
perecerá
[Aplausos]